what are you gonna do I have a plan and
it's really good I'm gonna postpone
telling him until you figure out what
I'm supposed to do so get cracking how
was this on me I'll do it
he's mailing me a penis what oh my god
it's he mailing me to whoever this is
send it to every woman in the entire
government he's gonna be so embarrassed
I mean that's a crazy accident no Andy
he did it on purpose you know what
respect that's a baller move pun
intended scuse me Chris Jerry's making
us look at dirty pictures on his
computer it is exactly because of that
lewd photo that I am here Ben and I are
launching a full investigation I want to
apologize to all the women and Jerry if
I could go back in time and cut your
eyeballs out I would wow that is so
sweet
thank you we are getting a lot of media
requests about this
so Leslie can you do pretty happily Oh
Susie can you do his TV show oh yeah mr.
mayor I promise you that we will find
the owner of that wiener and we will
punish him and Brookins Hey
I didn't know who to come to with this
but that picture there's something very
disturbing about the testicles I've
always felt the same way myself the
testicles are like the ears of the
genital system they serve a very
important function but they're not that
great to look at okay Wow no I I was
speaking medically they're enlarged I
think that maybe that guy is sick with
something perhaps a hernia or mumps and
Perkins you really know your testes
thank you
and Perkins hey did you maybe tell
people that I diagnosed that guy with
mumps based on his porn photo I did I'm
so proud of you okay because now I have
everyone in City Hall sending me
pictures of their junk asking me if they
have mumps oh my god your inbox is
literally filled with penises hmm I'm so
sorry
oh look Ed Miller from payroll
you